-Matthew, thank you
for being here. How are you?
-I'm very well. I'm very well.
Yeah, I'm very hot.
I'm less hot now
'cause the night has drawn i
but I'm in Sicily on holiday
with my family.
-I have been also lucky enough
to have gone to Sicily
in the past.
It's a beautiful place.
This is a very hot time of yea
in Sicily.
-It is, it is, yeah.
Yeah, it's very sweaty.
-[ Laughs ]
I mean, I guess we should
celebrate the fact
that you're on the other sid
of the Atlantic Ocean
where even though the pandemic
is not totally under control
people can at least travel
and holiday to some degree
-Yeah, this is true.
It's good.
And it's weird. Even where
I live in West London,
it feels like sort of,
people wearing masks,
but it's not sort of weird a
the early days of the lockdown
Central London is very strange
but kind of where people liv
is sort of okay, but who knows
-Fingers crossed that being okay
spreads. That would be nice.
So I'm very flattered to hear,
but your wife, Keeley Hawes,
who I'm a huge fan of as well,
she was on the show, and whe
you're on the show in person -
you obviously are being denied
this great honor --
you are given
a "Late Night" T-shirt,
and I hear it's getting
worn in your family.
-It's like hanging in rags
It's my youngest son's favorite.
His all-time favorite T-shirt,
which for a teenage boy,
it's a big deal.
It's a big deal.
-Please let him know
that I understand
that he's one shirt in deficit
but because his father's
on the show,
we will get it to him
eventually.
-Okay, wonderful, and I thin
Keeley very happily took awa
a mug from you
which has lost its holder,
so that now is a pen pot.
-I'll take it.
[ Laughs ]
-There's a lot of Seth
in our house.
-I should say, this is just,
it's not what
you're here promoting
but a lot of people
are looking for television shows
to watch during quarantine
I was introduced to both you
and Keeley on a fantastic show
"MI-5," that people should g
back and watch.
It's a fantastic,
fantastic show.
-We look very young.
We met on that show.
We came to Sicily to sort of
get away from it all,
and we found out very early on
in the airport that "Bodyguard,"
a TV show did that Keeley did,
a racy thriller
with Richard Madden...
-Yes, which I've also seen, yes.
-Yeah, it's on TV right no
in Italy.
So there's lots of sort of..
[ Speaks Italian ]
Yeah, so Keeley's
had a lot of attention.
-That's really exciting
because that's probably
three years ago for her now?
-Yeah, two years maybe, tw
or three, yeah. So it's good
-That's nice to have
a second life like that
in a foreign country.
-Yeah.
-I heard your family re-enacte
a British cooking show early o
when this first started?
-Yes, it's a sort of --
I think it's daytime TV show
called "Come Dine with Me.
It's horribly addictive,
if you're not doing
much in the day,
and anyway, we re-enacted it
And it was good, and the kid
took it very seriously
and we had a small cash prize.
The idea is you cook a meal from
scratch on consecutive night
and then you're judged, an
then you win the prize and yeah.
-Are you a decent cook,
all things considered?
-My vanity is that
I'm a very good cook.
And they ganged up on me
and I lost.
-Oh, well.
-Yeah, it was fun,
but not that --
I was sort of
manfully pretending
it was more fun than it was.
-They probably ganged up against
you out of petty jealousy, yes
-Kind of, yeah. They assumed
that I would win,
but I made onion bhajis,
and it was the wrong --
It was disgusting what I did
but it was, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-We tried to do virtuous thing
like reading hour,
which didn't work,
but it was good.
Lockdown was alright,
and they're all teenagers,
and we all got on.
It was sort of lovely actually
-I've got much younger childre
who it is not, their extra tim
with their parents,
I think, they're of the ag
where they're very happy
about it.
That's good if your teenager
survived through it.
I think that speaks well
to the level of parent you are
-I hope so, yeah.
I'd like to think.
-I want to congratulate yo
on your Emmy nomination
for "Succession."
It is -- Tom is as good
a character
as there is on TV and again,
having first been introduced
to you in far more serious fare,
I was blown away by
how funny this portrayal is.
When you first read
the character, did you --
could you appreciate
how funny it would be
or were you just taken
with how awkward it was?
Because it is the most awkward
scenes on television.
-I thought it was very --
Well, the pilot, the pilot
it was very funny.
He was so sort of
pathetically
ass-kissing to Logan
at the beginning.
He has this watch
that he's trying to give him
and then there's this sort o
really horrible scene at the end
where he turns on cousin Greg,
and that was the sort of thing
that made me think,
"Wow, maybe this --"
and then they just sort of
built on that.
The truth is it's a real joy
because as an actor,
you sort of -- sometimes
if you have a bit of success
in one kind of part,
then you're offered a similar --
you know, parts like that
and you end up
sort of not getting in a rut
but you sort of have to be canny
and try and do different things,
and this was such a blast.
It was such a breath
of fresh air.
-Well, it was a bunch
of different things.
One, you have
an American accent,
and it's like this sort of -
you all of a sudden
have no class or style
and very funny.
So a departure from everything
I knew you to be good at, so
and you and Nicholas Braun
are many --
much has been written about ho
it's television's best bromance.
He's also nominated in
your category.
So is Kieran Culkin.
All well-deserved.
Will there be some
bragging rights at stake her
if one of you were
to be the winner?
-Kieran has already descende
into threats of violence.
He's threatened to punch Nic
in the [bleep] if Nick wins.
-He seems very -- very prone
to rage, Kieran.
-Yeah, it's unprofessional apart
from anything else.
-Yeah.
-And I just won't go there
I'll just be very gracious
and I'm going to get
the Emmy people, if I win,
to sort of split it into three
maybe and so we can all share.
-That's very kind.
-I think so.
-How are you feeling about -
I think it's, you know --
it's sort of a mixed blessing --
There's nothing good
about the fact
that this will be
a virtual Emmys,
but, you know, you are saved
having to go through
this sort of dog and pony show
that is required of a nominee.
-Yeah, it's quite scary,
the whole thing.
I've been nominated
for various bits,
and it's very exciting
and then it's sort of --
it's just frightening.
It's partly because I've got t
get up and say something
if I win, and then you don't win
and then you sort of feel,
you know.
So there are consolations of i
not being a sort of zoo thing.
There are.
But I will miss
seeing everybody.
I miss the sort of convivialit
of it
and I miss, you know,
and inevitably in those things
you meet a lot of old friend
you haven't seen for ages,
and not just your cast,
so I'll miss that.
-Yeah, I always find the nices
part, when I look back on it
if you have the opportunit
as well to go up to somebody
who you never met before,
who you're a fan of.
And I think can genuinely --
people can tell when you're --
when you're just saying it
People can also tell when you go
out of your way to say,
"You were great."
-Thank you, yeah. Exactly.
-Another thing,
the conviviality,
I imagine you're missing i
being with the cast of the show.
You have a third season coming
that you have not been
able to film.
Do you guys --
Are you ever given any sense
of where the show is going
Because it is a show
that has great, you know,
twists and turns
for lack of a better term.
-Yeah, no, it's true.
Well, the first two seasons,
we were sort of
in blissful ignorance, or I was.
I think Brian
knew a little bit more,
and Jeremy wanted to
know very --
and so Jesse's
very sort of generous --
if people want to know, he'l
sort of give them little tidbits
and ideas about where
the character might go,
and I've had a little chat
and so I know a little bit
But not -- It's sort of lovely
not knowing.
And then you get the script.
-I can imagine, I mean,
it's such a tremendously
well-written show.
I imagine it jumps off the pag
that way
when you're reading it as well
-It does.
It's just brilliant.
The writing is just amazing,
and as you know, it's not --
The really wonderful writing
looks after you, as an actor
It all seems very sort of,
you think, "Oh, well, I know
how to play the scene
because it's sort of telling m
how to do it."
Because it's so brilliant.
It's so funny and angry
and odd and caustic
that it's just a joy
for an actor.
-Your Congressional testimon
scene was as uncomfortable
as I've been watching
in a long time.
-I was really scared.
I was so scared.
And my heart --
because they built
this thing
in the studio in Queens
and you walk in
and my heart was thumping
because there's
all these extras who are,
you know, the Senate,
and I'd been watching
little bits and pieces.
I think the Cohen thing
would've been on C-SPAN,
so I was sort of --
I'd watched little bits
and bobs, and yeah, awful.
-I mean, it's nice to know
that they'd actually built i
in a way that you as an acto
could also feel terrified
because that certainly
came across.
-No imagination. Yeah, yeah.
-You can never trust everythin
you read online,
but is it true that you are also
a John le Carré fan?
-I am. I am. My dad --
Yeah, I've got
a real soft spot.
My dad gave me -- "The Spy
Who Came in From the Cold"
was my -- that was first
sort of proper grown-up book
And yeah, I love --
"A Perfect Spy" is my favorite
novel of all time probably
-I watched that, I guess,
mini-series a long time ago.
Do you believe that's
a mini-series that holds up?
Should we also recommend tha
to everybody who's watching?
-I think so, yeah.
That's a really -- Yeah.
Brilliant acting and very --
I think it was the '80s.
Ray McAnally and Peter Egan.
-Oh, yeah, Ray McAnally, who -
-He played a version of his dad.
-Yes.
-Like his old man father, yeah
But I love the older he gets
he doesn't sort of --
John le Carré doesn't --
he sort of gets more politically
aware and angry, and he's not,
you know, he's not sort of
getting cozy in his old age.
-I know 'cause
from what I read about him
he just is living
a very lovely life,
but still very mad, which is -
I'm very impressed with.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright, so the takeaway
for everybody
should be to watch "Succession."
When you're done with that
"MI-5."
Only if, you know -- again
it's very long but I would say
if you're a fan of
you and Keeley,
I think just a couple seasons,
right?
-Yeah, 2, 2 1/2,
and then other people --
-Alright, great.
-Other people come in, and yeah.
-Yeah, then just move on
to "A Perfect Spy."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Hey, thanks so much
for making the time.
Congratulations.
So well-deserved.
-Great pleasure, thank you
Seth. Thank you very much.